روبوت دردشه الذكاء الاصطناعي او كما يسمى
تشات جي بي تي يكتب النثر والشعر والنصوص
البرمجيه باختصار انه يبدو كانسان يعترف
حتى باخطائه شبكه سي ان بي سي جربت
التطبيق على طريقتها لاختبار مدى دقه
المعلومات التي يقدمها حيث حاولت طلب
تنظيم رحله سفر فرد عليها بانها فكره
رائعه ثم رشح لها عده دول بناء على
تفضيلاتها لكن في ختام المحادثه خلصت
تقرير الى انه لا يمكن التعويل بشكل كامل
على الاجوبه التي يعطيها التطبيق فالخطا
الفادح وقع حينما قدم توصيه بفندق
على انه في بالي لكنه في الحقيقه يقع في
كندا
[موسيقى]
اما تذاكر السفر فلا يمكن لتطبيق الذكاء
الاصطناعي تقديم معلومات عن الرحله
الحاليه او المساعده في حجزها او تحديد
اسعارها فقط يقدم اسماء شركات الطيران
وحتى حينما سئل الروبوت عن رايه في افضل
شركه طيران اكتفى بالاجابه انه ليس لديه
تفضيلات او اراء شخصيه وفوق ذلك اشار الى
افضل خمس شركات طيران حسب سكاي تراكس خلال
العام 20 21 الا ان القائمه وفق سي ان بي
سي تعود للعام 2019
وبشكل او باخر فان الروبوت قد وقع هذه
المره في حفرته فبعد ان حاول ان يهدد
العالم بالرموز النوويه وبهندسه وباء يفتك
بالعالم وانه يحلم بان يصبح انسانا ها هو
بحروفه يؤكد انه مجرد تطبيق ذكاء اصطناعي